how many arrangements of the word
permutation
are there in which the vowels occur in
the order a e
i o u from left to right though not
necessarily
together okay disclaimer uh i
i think permutations and combination is
a really interesting topic but i
i don't like it um because i'm not very
good at it it's always really confusing
it's hard to know whether your answer is
right or not and the person who sent
this to me
um got an answer it disagreed with the
answers in the um
in the exercise so how do you know how
what's the actual way to
go about getting the answer and you know
there's lots of different ways to get
the answer
lots of different methods which one's
the best so i've done a lot of thinking
about this
and here's the answer that i've come up
with okay now by the way i'm going to
set this out the way that i would
set out an answer if this was an exam
that i was doing
and there's going to be you know full-on
sentences and that kind of thing and
that's what perms and comms is about
like you have to explain your logic
and not just have numbers down with no
explanation as to why
because when someone's marking it what
they're looking for is an explanation of
understanding a demonstration of
understanding and not just
can you you know pluck out random
numbers which will get you right answer
at the end so here we go um the word
permutation let's just think about that
for a second before you think about uh
the vowels
okay the word permutation has one two
three four five seven eight nine ten
eleven
letters okay eleven letters right
so the first thing i would set out is
that
forgetting about what the letters are
right and any kinds of conditions on
them i'm gonna add conditions as i go
i'm gonna say there are 11 factorial
ways
of arranging 11 letters so
that's pretty sort of standard
arrangements before you even get to
permutations and combinations as
a topic you've got you know 11 slots and
how many letters can you how many
choices do you have for the first slot
you've got 11 because you've got 11
that haven't been picked then how about
the next one well you've got 10 left
and then 9 and so on so when you
multiply them all together you get 11
factorial
okay right so this is kind of our
baseline
right this is this is my my first thing
which i'm going to say
and i'm now going to try and be drill
down and become more specific
and add conditions on okay so
let's think about the next thing um when
you have a think about all of the
arrangements that you're going to get
these 11 factorial relationships massive
number
okay in these arrangements the vowels
will not always be in order
so that's that's a bad thing for us
right
because we only want the ones where the
vowels are in order
okay so how many of these 11 factorial
arrangements
ways how many of them have the vowels in
order
well to answer that i want to think
about
how many different ways are there to get
the vowels right how many different ways
are there
to order the vowels and the answer is
because there are five vowels
a e i o u right how many ways are they
there to reorder them well the answer is
there are five factorial ways
to order the vowels right
now here's the thing out of those five
factorial what's that uh i think it's
120 off the top of my head
out of those five factorial ways how
many of those ways am i interested in
and the answer is i'm only interested in
one way the specific
way where all of the vowels are in this
order and this order only
okay so since there are 5 factorial 120
different ways and i'm only interested
in one of them
right that means i've over counted by a
factor of 5 factorial or a factor of
11 factorial of sorry 120 right
so therefore there are 11 factorial
divided by
5 factorial ways where
i've got 11 letters and the vowels are
in order
okay so you can you see how because i've
i've over counted in my original
calculation to compensate i divide right
that'll divide me down and get 5
factorial
less as a factor ways of arrangements
okay so now i've got so far
this is an 11 letter word right with 11
letters to choose from
now i've i've narrowed down that i only
won the
want the ones where the a e i o and u
are in order
okay now i have a think about are there
any other limitations and the answer is
yes
because in my word two of the letters
are identical
okay the two t's now that means that
i can arrange those two t's in two
factorial ways
if i had three t's it'd be three
factorial more ways right so again i've
over counted
because this permutation this this way
of spelling it
if i swap these two t's around would
look exactly the same but
this way of counting would double them
up right so
therefore since there are two identical
letters
right and again like i said i'm actually
going to write this down as part of my
answer
because it demonstrates that i know
where the numbers that i'm writing are
coming from right
we've over counted by a factor of two
factorial
okay so just like with the five
factorial before i have to divide
through by that right
and this is all the conditions right so
therefore
there are 11 factorial on 5 factorial
2 factorial ways and when you punch that
into calculator
you get 166 320 ways
in which you can arrange those letters
given those conditions